you have to have some type of faith if
you're in the stock market
i don't think all of it is just skill i
think some of it is also luck
maybe it's his daily ritual of lighting
sage but lately pablo batista has been
lucky
he made eleven thousand 000 selling
gamestop stock
and since losing his job as a cook
working from his bronx apartment as a
day trader was really paying off
we up a grand boys we up a grand but
then the platform he was using
started putting limits on trades i saw
it
like these guys are trying to stop me
when i'm at my peak
leading up to gamestop i had already
been making money
i've been making a lot of money since
2019 the volume
of trading by small-time investors like
him has grown from
10 to roughly 25 percent of the market
they're credited with boosting gamestop
from under 20 dollars to above 300
a share outsmarting hedge funds who bet
against the struggling retailer
without ever setting foot on wall street
pablo and other
so-called retail investors have been
flexing their financial muscle
with the help of technology and social
media hitting institutional investors
right where it hurts
their bottom line but even before
gamestop sounded the alarm the market
was at record highs
a trend experts say is unsustainable
i don't think people really understand
that especially the younger generation
they think
you know these stocks in the market is
supposed to go up and up up that's what
they're supposed to do but no
we're supposed to have corrections we're
supposed to have consolidations we
haven't seen any of that
brock pierce is a former actor who's
made millions investing
and believes it's the hedge funds not
individual investors
who need to be restricted what we're
seeing
is the democratization
of the financial system a line is being
drawn which side of the fence do you
stand on are you with the people
or are you with a small group of
institutions that are profiting
from killing companies oh yeah it's
ripping bro let's go boys
as for pablo he knows investing comes
with risks
i think i'm kind of where i'm at right
now because
i took that risk risks he believes he
and other individuals are entitled to
take
new highs every week though new highs
every week kristin salumi al jazeera new
york